[mysterious music]
Alex, Trevor,
congratulations, you
boys are now in the
third and final round
of this competition.
And now it's time to send
you back to your home forges
to recreate this iconic weapon--
J. Neilson's war scythe.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in four days.
Yes, sir.
[rock music]
ALEX: I'm back in my home forge.
I got all my own tools.
But I am certainly going to
miss having a power hammer.
I've got to do all this by hand.
It's going to be a
much bigger challenge.
Today, I am rough forging the
scythe portion of the weapon.
There's just a lot of material.
And I'm doing all this
with a hand hammer.
So it's just going
to take a while.
So as I'm drying out my billet,
my hammer just breaks on me.
I had to switch to a
different hammer mid-hear.
So just one other thing
I got to deal with.
At the start of day 2,
I'm going to work on forging
out another scythe head.
I'm going to use my first
blade as a template,
hopefully get everything
cleaned up so I can
heat treat by this afternoon.
Now, the storm is starting
to come back through.
I'm hoping we don't
have a problem.
Oh, the power went out.
I'm really not going to be able
to use my mill or my grinder.
Without these power
tools, I'm not going
to be able to finish my blade.
This is not what I want.
ALEX: It's the start to day 2.
So I decided to make the bottom
blade out of 1095 so it doesn't
need to be terribly flexible.
Everything seems
to be going well.
So I'm about to start grinding.
And I go to check my
blade, and the main blade
is under 12 inches.
I'm almost a quarter of
an inch under parameters.
Luckily, I haven't
started grinding yet,
so I can still go back and
forge the extra bit out.
So I'm really glad I found this
problem before it was too late.
[whirring]
Finished all the rough grinding.
Now, I want to get the quench.
Heat treat went well.
I'm really glad day 2 is done.
I feel like I got
a lot accomplished.
So I'm definitely feeling
a lot better today.
TREVOR: The power came back on.
But right now, I just want
to get that smaller blade
heat treated and work
on the bigger blade,
and then get into
making the handle.
Everything looks
pretty straight.
The next step right now is going
to be heat treating the forks.
And then, I'll finish everything
up and make it look real nice.
[rock music]
The forks heat treated great.
I'm going to use this
aluminum bat to test it.
If the aluminum bat
damages these forks any,
it's a problem.
That's pristine.
I have to work on
this wood handle now.
Everything is
fitting really well.
I'm going to move on
to the detail work.
[howling]
ALEX: So it's the
morning of day 4.
Right now, all I got to
do is the final assembly.
I'm in the homestretch.
It feels very tight.
So judges, we're looking forward
to you swinging this blade.
It's going to be a beast.
And I hope it handles well.
Oh, jeez.
[spooky music]
Trevor, Alex, welcome
back to the forge.
You boys have had four
days at your home forges
to work on your war scythes.
Your blades will now be
subjected to three tests.
There will be a strength test,
a sharpness test, but up first,
our very own dealer of death,
the doer of deadly deeds,
the kill test master,
Doug Marcaida.
[evil laughter]
Yeah, he just looks
like a murderer.
I am really nervous.
[rock music]
All right, Alex.
The balance is light,
allowing it to be a very
fast weapon that you can use.
It will handle long-handed
or for close quarters.
Your weapon will kill.
All right, Trevor,
trick-or-treat?
Treat.
Indeed.
It will be a treat.
[rock music]
All right, Trevor, the tip alone
penetrates deeply into the gut,
and the edges here
are sharp enough to,
well, make him lose his head.
Overall, sir, it will kill.
Thank you, sir.
All right, smiths, welcome
to the strength test,
the dreaded coffin challenge.
[thunder]
I'm gonna take these bones
and beat them repeatedly
into the blade of your scythes.
And Alex, you're locked
in and ready to go first.
You're ready?
Yep.
That's what I want to hear.
[laughs]
[suspenseful music]
[rock music]
[grunts]
Alex, you survived.
Good job.
The only issue I have, you have
some slight rolling on the edge
and the head of this moves.
So it's not secure anymore.
But your edge held up great.
Good job.
Thank you.
How you feeling, Trevor?
- Pretty good right now.
- Good.
Well, we'll see you
feel in a minute.
[suspenseful music]
[rock music]
Nice job, Trevor.
It held up well.
Your edge is still
good, nice and sharp.
Everything's still tight.
Good job.
Thank you.
All right, bladesmiths,
this is the sharpness
test, the zombie surprise.
To test the edge of your weapon,
I going to take your scythe
and cut through this rope,
thereby releasing the surprise.
All right.
Alex, you're up first.
You ready?
Certainly.
[rock music]
(WHISPERS) Shit.
All right, Alex it
cut easily on the rope.
When you're puncturing this,
it cuts through and slices.
It will cut.
Thank you.
All right, Trevor, your turn.
So you ready?
Oh, yeah.
[suspenseful music]
[thunder]
[rock music]
All right, Trevor.
The edge that you
have here lends itself
to cut the rope much easier.
When you're
puncturing, it starts
to cut all the way through.
Overall, sir, it will cut.
Thank you.
All right, bladesmiths, you
guys have done fantastic work.
But only one of you can be
the "Forged in Fire" champion.
And that champion is Trevor.
Congratulations, you are the
new "Forged in Fire" champion.
Alex, unfortunately, your
blade took some damage
in our strength test.
You did great work, my friend.
But at this time, I have to ask
you to please exit the forge.
Ultimately, it came
down to the construction.
Unfortunately, mine just
came a little bit loose.
And that was enough.
One of my main goals was that
I wanted to go the whole way.
I certainly did that.
I'm very proud of myself.
I think I definitely
made a blade
that can intimidate anyone.
Well, Trevor, the
judges all agree,
you made a damn near
perfect war scythe,
which has earned you the
title of "Forged in Fire"
champion and a
check for $10,000.
Good job, brother.
Come on forward and
shake our hands.
TREVOR: I won!
Woo!
I think the biggest thing I
learned was to keep on trying.
If something doesn't go your
way, don't get upset about it,
just keep moving forward.
This was a perfect
Halloween experience.
I feel like I just
went trick-or-treating
and I got a pillowcase
full of candy.
[rock music]
[evil laughter]
[screaming]